hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to reading your
comments jibbity bop Ba Duba whoa
that's wrong okay mark tell Amy you're
preg an enhance okay all right hey I'm
crew cannonade I loves potato do you I
do love the here is the third pole
dancing video coming out anytime stares
intently
[Music]
yeah I've been I've been promising the
third pole dancing video for a long time
now and you know what I'm just gonna say
after the tour we are definitely going
to do that and I'm not saying like after
the tour for a nebulous amount of time
we're going to schedule it so that as
soon as we come back from the tour we're
going to make another pole dancing video
out of that and it'll be super cool not
mark sing to a potato to unlock chicas
ancient powers
[Music]
dear mark I have a question for you how
would you pronounce drakensberg
kwazulu-natal no maybe the internet
knows penis Frank I'm Malfoy according
to hazel no direct please believe the
crank game plays champ drakensberg
dragons Berg I love dragons I was just
like crying so sink in or something but
doing this because I love you mark I
would do anything for you so Jacobs fur
jackets Berg I don't know screw it I
just love you so much mark and I can't
wait to see you at the Houston tour soon
so nice sure Ricans Berg kwazulu-natal
close seem that hard I'm probably wrong
cracks in drachten [ __ ] you oh my
feelings okay but I think the answer to
that question is no one knows it's a
mystery forever hey Mark I'm graduating
high school soon do you have any advice
for me if you actually see this I'm a
huge fan
I've been watching for about 3 years
well thank you so much for watching and
if I have any advice to give even though
my Yonder years of high school seems so
long ago now but if I have any advice to
give it's never stopped trying new
things like no matter what you're doing
even if you're going to college or if
you're going straight into work or
whatever you're doing the world is open
to you but it won't be handed to you
high school is structured in the way
that you do exactly what you're told and
then you get a piece of paper that says
you're ready for the world but what it
doesn't teach you is that the world is
what you make of it like even if you're
going into college try hobbies join
clubs meet
meeting people is probably the best
skill of it you could possibly ever
learn and you got to do it with baby
steps by taking it very slow and I went
to college after high school I didn't
take those steps to go out and push my
comfort zone out it wasn't until after
college that I really started to find
who I was when I started doing YouTube
because I continually tried to do new
things so just keep that spirit and
you'll be fine
you should let Amy do your makeup okay
hi welcome to the boyfriend makeup tag
good ciao
girlfriend hi welcome
hey it's makeup time make it as good as
you can hope for the best
hold on you know why I like the gate so
specific go for it make the potato
beautiful two potatoes we have a million
users who knew I'm just gonna give me
the professor over yeah good laughing I
go first
I was just trying to live okay that was
done in time what's done is that
McCain's a good there you go I assume
I'm beautiful oh this is the first time
I'm seeing myself yeah that's a thing
mark i sexually identify as an
undercooked potato me too
my cool yeah do it try not to cry
challenge we need to see you cry more
often why do you need that I mean I
could do it try not to smile which
almost made me cry anyway but no no good
mark did you ever had a hard time in
life as a kid I'm Kevin been having hard
time since five yes and it's a little
bit odd for me to be serious when I'm
wearing this makeup but yeah you know I
grown up as a kid I didn't have the
worst childhood but you know my parents
got divorced and then we didn't have a
lot of money but I never really thought
of it as like the worst childhood that I
could possibly imagine because I got to
spend so much time with my dad and if
you could see me now I bet he'd be so
proud of me right now
hi I hope you don't die horribly in your
sleep at exactly 341 a.m. thank you me
neither
that'd be bad I think the best quote
I've ever heard you say is I destroyed
Detroit for a piece of cake yeah it's
funny about that we're doing a tour now
and we're gonna have a show in Detroit
and somehow they expect me to apologize
no damn it I'm not going to apologize I
got cake out of the deal
you're a scrub thanks hey Mark why not
pick up Mario maker again I mean if you
really want to frustrate yourself
there's a common misconception here I
don't wanna frustrate myself it just
happens that way and I'm so competitive
when I'm playing it that I don't want to
lose to the game have you found out
something about yourself while becoming
more and more popular in the last few
years because everyone views such a lot
of your life that you don't like about
yourself or do like about yourself you
didn't notice before that's actually a
really interesting question because yeah
I've discovered a lot of who I am in the
five years that I've been doing YouTube
like I've discovered like what I want
and what I want to accomplishing what
motivates me and and it's hard to nail
down just one thing but I think the most
important thing that I learned once I
started doing this and I guess you could
attribute to getting more popular but
what I what I realize is that I can
actually take control of my life
I can I can do what I want to do and I
can do it the way that I want to do it
so long as I put my mind to it and it's
not even like a motivational thing where
you're like you can achieve anything you
can be an astronaut if you want to I
wish but it's more of a thing where
what's in my life is under my control
and I have the choice
I literally have the choice to influence
my own life and and in doing so that can
ripple across to everyone I meet and
that's a very powerful thing and it's a
very powerful thing to learn and
understand and I think it's very cool
that we all have the same ability to do
that we all can change the course of our
life just by making one decision and in
doing so that can ripple across the
entire world and that is really really
cool to hear really cool to learn hard
to get serious when I'm prepping makeup
like this but you know I try so anyway
that is all the time I got for reading
your comments thank you everybody so
much for your comments I did pull from
other social platforms so if you've got
requests of me questions to ask
different things you want to send my way
be sure to write down the comments below
or anywhere else in the social sphere
thank you again everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye